a rocker takes a stab at shakespearean
horror while two snl alums try to keep a
straight face
from oscar nominees to mcu favorites you
won't believe who's gotten a paycheck
from lifetime
in a 2020 interview with tv insider
sigourney weaver called her role as
fundamentalist mother turned lgbtq plus
advocate mary griffith in the 2009
lifetime movie prayers for bobby the
hardest part she'd ever played from an
emotional standpoint the role of based
on the experiences of the real life
griffith required weaver to take an
unsympathetic turn as a homophobic
mother who tried to convert her son
played by ryan kelly after he came out
as gay after his suicide she rejects her
bigoted views and becomes a powerful
voice in support of gay rights if i just
listen to my son when he poured his
heart out to me
i would not be standing here today
weaver earned emmy golden globe and
screen actors guild nominations for her
performance as griffith who came to
believe that her church's interpretation
of scripture was wrong and worked
tirelessly until the end of her life for
pro-gay causes reversals of faith and
demoral searches are no small feats to
depict on screen but weaver's
performance taps directly into
griffith's anguish over losing her son
to find both healing and renewed purpose
depicting griffith as a heartless figure
wouldn't have made her newfound beliefs
and direction so moving or being
accurate to the real-life griffith
weaver instead does a heavy lifting to
find the humanity and humility in
griffith which lends extraordinary depth
to her performance
made us a point in christian stuart's
career when she was just emerging from
juvenile roles and long before her vote
to stardom in the twilight saga and the
string of critically praised adult
performances the 2004 lifetime drama
speak confirms her exceptional acting
talent stewards plays a high schooler
who has difficulty talking after being
sexually assaulted at a house party
speak which premiered at the sundance
film festival in 2004 before airing on
lifetime and showtime in 2005 is based
on a young adult novel by laurie hulls
anderson both the source material and
the film handle that subject matter with
great sensitivity and emotional depth
speak gets tremendous support from the
uniformly excellent cast which includes
elizabeth perkins and d.b sweeney as
stuart's parents steve zahn is a
sympathetic teacher and michael angerano
as a fellow outcast who befriends stuart
but it's stewart's performance that
anchors the film and elevates it beyond
typical lifetime fare the trials of her
character are a lot for any actor to
carry but stuart shoulders it with
strength and maturity
jason momoa's acting career was still in
its embryonic phase when he signed on to
play a mostly shirtless love interest
for virginia madison in a 2003 lifetime
movie tempted
you know what you need you get in the
water
it's healing
i'm not the best swimmer
i am mamoa completed his first screen
assignment a two season run on baywatch
hawaii shortly before signing until
tempted despite its hawaiian setting
temted was actually filmed in new south
wales australia
maggie greenwald is talented and
award-winning director of such
well-regarded indie dramas as a ballad
of little joe and suncatcher benefits
from the natural beauty of her film's
locations and her cast the film pairs
mamoa with virginia madison as a woman
who travels with the ashes of her former
guardian and native hawaiian there she
meets momoa who plays her late
guardian's nephew and sparks fly despite
the fact that madsen has a husband
waiting for her on the mainland mamoa
who is a naturally charismatic and
intense performer doesn't have much to
do here beyond staring longingly while
wearing as little clothing as possible
if you're a fan of his work in aquaman
dune and sea this isn't an exemplary
showcase for his abilities but if you're
interested in his chiseled build tempted
is a two-hour box of eye candy
though mark ruffalo is one of
hollywood's busiest and most acclaimed
actors today the emmy grammy tony and
oscar nominee was largely anonymous in
the 1990s ruffalo's resume during this
period included low budget horror and
indie films but he also kept busy with
occasional forays into tv like on the
second day of christmas which aired on
lifetime television in 1997 directed by
james frawley on the second day of
christmas takes place in a department
store during the holidays but it's no
miracle on 34th street despite being a
little girl patsy played by lauren pratt
is an experienced pickpocket who works
as a team with her aunt played by mary
stuart masterson ruffalo is a department
store security guard who catches them in
the act so writer brian holfeld bends
logic to force a trio to spend christmas
together while awaiting sentencing
christmas is supposed to be a time of
compassion don't you feel the least bit
sorry for us look lady you choose the
life of crime you got to take the
consequences while many holiday romance
couples seem forced together by the plot
ruffalo and masterson's chemistry helps
to make their eventual connection seem
believable
in 2011 lifetime presented 5 an
anthology feature featuring stories
about the impact of breast cancer on
patients and their families the project
created by marta kaufman drew high
profile talent behind the camera
including jennifer aniston alicia keys
and patty jenkins it also attracted
talented performers like patricia
clarkson tracy ellis russ rosario dawson
and tony shalhoub two years later
lifetime returned to the 5 format for
call me crazy which focused its quintet
of stories on mental health issues 5
gained an emmy award nomination for
casting and numerous nominations for its
actors and directors so when the network
decided to return to the format for
2013's call me crazy a five film they
garnered an even more impressive roster
of talent directors included oscar
winner laura dern bryce dallas howard
ashley judd and bonnie hunt while three
oscar winners jennifer hudson octavia
spencer and melissa leo each headlined
one of the stories
by the age of 20 kiersten dunst had a
massive impressive body of work in films
and on television she earned her first
of four golden globe nominations at the
age of 10 for interview with the vampire
and featured in such popular and
critical hits as little women jumanji
wag the dog and the virgin suicides
during this incredibly busy period the
future oscar and emmy nominee also
starred in a lifetime original movie 15
and pregnant dunce is a titular teenager
tina who becomes pregnant by her
deadbeat boyfriend ray played by daniel
coons she decides to keep the baby
causing friction between her separated
parents played by park overall and david
andrews and her sister played by julia
wellen the film hits all the pregnancy
drama tropes tina's dramatic reveal ray
bailing on being a dad and a birth
sequence filled with screaming but it
also does well in dividing the focus
between tina and her extended family and
friends you're not my leader i don't act
and think like you well it wouldn't be
so terrible for you to be a little less
shallow maybe a little bit more
responsible you're not that great either
you know dunce portrays the confusion of
teen life and the upheaval of an
unexpected pregnancy with the same depth
and confidence she's shown throughout
her career the majority of her scenes
pitter against overall and andrews two
extremely capable stage trained
performers and she holds her own in
every scene
the drama stockholm pennsylvania
surprised many sundance film goers by
premiering on lifetime in 2015 rather
than hitting theaters after garnering
mostly positive reviews at the festival
that year the film features an
impressive cast led by oscar nominee
sergio ronan and emmy winner cynthia
nixon and tackles a difficult subject
the impact of an abduction on both the
victim and her family
ronan plays 22 year old leia who was
held captive from the age of four by a
man with apocalyptic delusions named ben
played by jason isaacs eventually she
returns to her parents played by nixon
and david washowski that she barely
knows what follows is at times an even
more intense take on life after trauma
than is depicted in room with free
lassen leia's refusal to accept her
parents and fund recollections of life
with ben
all signs point to stockholm syndrome
ronin avoids the pitfall of overplaying
a deeply damaged character
she remains quiet instead of explosive
or unhinged allowing the viewer to guess
at her true emotional state
when lifetime steps out of the romantic
thriller of suburban drama box the end
result is often a high-profile project
like call me crazy or betty and coretta
trying something different really meant
casting courtney love dominic monaghan
and paul walter hauser in a horror
themed series based on shakespeare's and
midsummer's night dream of course that's
exactly what lifetime provided with
2017's and midsummer's nightmare
produced in partnership with a e studios
after the success of their hit drama
unreal lifetime appeared to be aiming
for american horror story territory with
a midsummer's nightmare a midsummer's
nightmare opens on a strong note with a
character dragged through the woods by
mass figures that hurl her into an open
grave filled with bees once that initial
shock fades away however the film
becomes a routine mix of tristing and
low wattage mystery
the campus
time to scamper
a deadly adoption is sort of a
meta-lifetime movie it's a parody of the
network's sudsy plotting with will
ferrell and kristen wiig playing the
sort of hapless suburbanites usually
portrayed by the likes of eric roberts
and kelly martin though produced by
farrell's former partner adam mckay a
deadly adoption unfolds with an entirely
straight face requiring the audience to
find the laughs in the inherent
absurdity of the story itself feral and
wig who work hard to achieve a sort of
earnest blindness are robert and sarah a
married couple who lose their second
child in an unfortunate dark accident
they soon decide on using a surrogate to
have another child but their prospective
birth mother bridget played by lifetime
vet jessica lowndes is more than she
seems she's actually obsessed with
robert farrell's trademark near hysteria
and wigs over dramatic referees are put
to good use here but the humor is almost
too subtle there's just a razor thin
margin between the comedy and the
histrionics of a real lifetime movie
[Music]
you